there's a chance that you could not be
able to maybe come home and you would be
deported is there any truth to that or
you kind of just coming yeah I mean
there's a chance of anything happening
you know what I mean there's nothing
that in life that you know is certain
but I mean you know we'll deal with that
when you know when I get out when I get
out that's another issue so we'll figure
that up Joe and Teresa Giudice are now
facing that reality after a judge ruled
in immigration court on Wednesday that
the 46 year old Real Housewives of New
Jersey star will be deported to his
native Italy at the end of his 41 month
prison sentence it's news the family
wasn't prepared to hear according to a
source who fell ziti that Teresa is
devastated by the ruling I just want to
get out you know as quickly as I can and
do whatever I can
Joe has been in prison since 2016 he
entered a Federal Correctional
Institution after pleading guilty to
multiple charges of fraud in 2014
alongside Teresa she served her own a
year long prison sentence before Joe so
that the couple's four daughters were
never without a parent in the home I
wish my honey was here but I'm doing the
best as I could Joe has 30 days to
appeal the deportation ruling but a
source tells e t if he doesn't win the
couple's marriage may be over quote as
much as Teresa said she would live in
Italy with Joe in the past that most
likely won't happen though a separate
source says quote Teresa loves him and
wants to ensure her children grow up
with their father
do the right thing I'm better there so
he's like that's what he keeps saying
the way he is when he comes out he's
like I will show you I can't wait to see
that Teresa was hopeful about her future
with Joe when et sat down with her last
year
how much do you and Joe talk about life
when he's done with his sentence and
what your marriage will look like
listen we don't I'm not predicting the
future anymore like wherever are you
know my life takes me
it'll take me I'll embrace it you know
fully you know and whatever my journey
is it is are you hoping for at least the
best
oh yeah and when you're into status yes
I'm hoping for the best
yeah of course I want us to to always be
together I mean that's what you know
that's what life's about
[Music]
[Applause]